ces chevaux n'appartiennent plus à
madame von renton une finlandaise de 49
ans qui avait acheté le haras de la
baume il ya cinq ans l'association la
réserve qui défend la cause animale a
été mandatée par les pouvoirs publics
pour une durée de trois mois afin de
vendre tous les chevaux en danger ou à
défaut les placer dans une famille
d'adoption
selon patrice le guen le président de
cette association joint par téléphone
tous ces chevaux sont en sous poids et
certains présentent des blessures type
barbelés les clôtures électriques
étaient présentes mais pas toujours
alimenté les boks par ailleurs sont dans
un état lamentable
ces tissus n'a pas vraiment surpris le
maire de chrono ça m'a plutôt rassuré
parce que on se trouve face à un
problème qui est déjà ancien et de voir
des chevaux maigre 100 ans en nourriture
et en boissons
je suis une mère mais je suis aussi
vétérinaire et donc ça fait un petit peu
ça fait quelque chose et on est content
que la puissance publique se soient mis
en route pour essayer de d'alimenter et
de se soigner ses animaux depuis le
début de l'année on chevaux sont morts
dans ce haras nous n'avons pu joindre
aujourd'hui la propriétaire en revanche
un jeune homme qui venait régulièrement
l'aider depuis trois semaines et
espérait être embauchés a bien voulu
nous parler hors caméra selon lui
beaucoup de choses n'allaient pas dans
cet élevage mais il s'agissait pour lui
de négligence et pas de maltraitance
le tableau qu'il brosse donne
effectivement l'impression d'une
propriétaires dépassés par l'ampleur de
la tâche